Hello, I'm Brian Rubin and
I am here with Tom and Nina,
and we are going to talk about
the weirdest stories that...
Would...
Let's try that one again, start over.
Sorry. Disney.
Didney. Didney, you know? Didney?
Hi, I'm Brian and I'm here with Tom and Nina to
talk about the weirdest stories that Disney could
make into a movie next. This was something that
I thought a lot about because I'm a big fan of
Disney movies. We're all fans of Disney movies
to varying degrees. Disney has adopted some
weird stuff. Everyone kind of thinks about
the Disney princesses and the fairytales.
That's where everyone's mind goes first. But
they've also adopted some strange things like the
Hunchback of Notre Dame, a story in which the lead
characters die. It doesn't happen in the movie.
Pocahontas, which is actual history and did not
involve a friendly raccoon and hummingbird pal.
You don't know that.
Involved much more smallpox than that actually.
Much more smallpox, at least 50% more smallpox.
Treasure Planet, that's Treasure
Island, but in space. So for my pick-
Never made the connection until just now.
I had two picks. One, I think is a good idea.
And the other, I think is a bad idea but I like
the name so much. The first idea is Gulliver's
Travels. I think that it would be good for Disney
to adapt Gulliver's Travels, which is a
famous novel, I guess like a proto novel in a way,
written by Jonathan Swift, the famous satirist.
Basically he uses Gulliver's Travels to
make fun of and point out the flaws in English,
Imperial society and things like that. But
there've been adaptations down the road that
have had very little to do with that original
satirical intention, like say the Jack
Black version of Gulliver's Travels.
That is exactly what I was thinking of, yeah.
Which stars Emily blunt, and she
had to turn down Black Widow to
do Gulliver's Travels. So that's why
Scarlett Johansson is the Black Widow.
Is that a fact?
As far as I know, that's a fact.
That hurts my heart.
But so, in Gulliver's Travels, you've got this
guy, Gulliver and he's just kind of goes around
traveling. He goes to Lilliput and he meets all
the teeny tiny Lilliputians. And then he goes to
other places with names that are hard to pronounce
so I'm not going to try, but then he sees very,
very big people. And then he goes to a
place where people live in the clouds,
and he goes to a place where people are actually
horses. And so I feel like Disney could really do
a lot where they just kind of take that framework
and do something different with it, right?
Like Treasure Planet is Treasure Island in space.
You could do the same thing with Gulliver's
Travels, set it in space, set it in a complete
fabricated world that's just a fantasy world with
different places and different characters,
that isn't so keyed into those specific
things. But anyway, Gulliver's Travels seems
like one of those things that could work.
Would you want it to maintain
the kind of satirical tone?
Because we're talking about Jonathan Swift, right?
Right.
Who wrote this book. He
also wrote A Modest Proposal
where he advocated for eating
babies, which a lot of people-
Which is something I think that maybe we
should still consider. But anyway, go on. Yes.
You definitely want that on tape, okay.
That's really more Pixar territory though.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Oh yeah, yeah.
They've got the pathos for it. No, but
Swift was a biting satirist. And so would
you want a Disney adaptation of that to
maintain that in a clever Pixar kind of way?
Would you want it to be a little more fun?
I think asking Disney to effectively satire
the real world might be asking a lot,
but Wall-E is a pretty good
satire of consumerist culture.
Right. Exactly.
It's doable. I don't know how
they'd do it and I don't know-
It's got to be the right creative team.
It's got to be... it's a very, it's
a tough needle to thread. But I think
that considering if we're talking about Disney
wanting to kind of work on something that's
really recognizable and also something that's
still very much a blank canvas... no one's
going to go see a Gulliver's Travels movie
that Disney puts out in 2025 and be like,
"Hey, where's the horse people?"
Nobody's read Gulliver's Travels.
Also, there hasn't been a successful
film adaptation. The Jack Black one is-
I don't think so.
... largely forgotten.
There was a TV series with Ted
Danson that also no one remembered.
Yeah. So what I'm saying is it's kind of like a
Great Gatsby conundrum where there
just hasn't been a good one yet.
But I think-
But that's my own-
I think-
... bug but whatever.
Yeah. I think that there's enough that
they could do with it that they could stay
satirical but still tell a
pretty good Disney style story.
Yeah. I Think I-
That was my-
I would definitely see a Disney Gulliver's Travel.
My other pick was adapting Merchant of
Venice, but calling it Merchant of Venus,
and they're aliens, and that's it.
That's as far as I got with it.
Shakespeare in Space. Love it.
Don't write a single other word. That is...
Yeah.
That came out of the barrel perfect.
Someone write this man a giant check
and get this movie greenlit now.
It's mine. I own it. Merchant of Venus.
Coming to a theater near you.
I bet if I Google that, I definitely won't
see anyone else who's made that joke before.
No.
Absolutely not.
It's my original idea.
So original. Yeah.
Nailed it.
Love it.
Merchant of Venus. So anyway-
Out of the gate.
Yeah. So Tom, what about you? What's the weirdest
story that you think Disney should adapt next?
Okay. I have three ideas. Because as far as I can
tell Disney, they have three separate things that
make the money right now, once you set
aside Star Wars and Marvels. In terms
of Disney stories, you can either do a sequel
to a cartoon that already made money. Right?
Mm-hmm.
Right.
You can do a quasi respectful appropriation of
a cultural story that you have music set to.
Or you can do a live action origin
story of a villain a la Wicked. Right?
Mm-hmm.
Okay so my first idea, we could do Hercules
two. Or if you'll follow me, Herc-Two-Les.
Love it. Love it. I love it.
Not enough movies do that.
Following the-
Not enough movies put the two-
It's really good, right? No, I know.
... or three in the middle of a
word. Everybody should be doing it.
It's such a clever gag and-
It's hilarious.
... everybody should be doing it more often.
Slaps every time.
I know what it is. Sometimes I wake up in the
middle of night throwing up from how funny it is
when people use a two in the title of their thing.
So Herc-Two-Le's. What I felt
we could do is follow the-
You should maybe see a doctor.
I'm not a well man. What happens in Herc-Two-Les
is we follow Hercules and he's married to Megara,
and we follow their marriage through the actual
mythological story that the original story follows
wherein Hera, Hercules' kind of step-mom I
guess, the goddess realizes that she's not
actually Hercules' mom. So she drives him crazy,
and then he murders Megara and his children.
That's how you get butts in seats,
Well, I think it could make for some
great musical numbers, like bring the
muses back like... oh my God. And then they cry,
and Pain and Panic are there. You've got the
Bobcat Goldthwait character and the other guy-
Yeah, he needs to come back.
Max Headroom. They're just... ah.
Look, it's never too early to introduce young
children to devastating Greek
myths. That's all I'm saying.
You're not wrong, right?
I'm right. Yeah.
So then we get to follow Hercules through
the rest of the story. What's really cool
about this is Hercules is his own bad guy at this
point. So we just kind of cut James
Woods out of the equation. And then-
I'm fine with that.
Yeah, I don't need him.
All right rhe end, I don't know if you
guys... the way that Hercules dies in
the story is somebody gets tricked
into putting a poison shirt on him
and it hurts so bad that he burns himself
to death. He throws himself on a pyre-
Classic.
... and then burns himself to death.
That's how most Disney movies should end.
I'm glad that you said that.
My second idea for an original story, an original
cartoon would be the Aztec myth, Quetzalcoatl-
Oh Jesus Christ. Okay.
The serpent god of the wind. I've got kind
of this whole plan for this that I think
could be kind of fun where he's already
a God, but he wants to be a star, right?
Yeah.
This whole Hollywood kind of a situation.
Because I don't know if you know this but
in the original story, what happens is that he
gets drunk and then hooks up with his sister
and then get so embarrassed
that he burns himself to death.
This is a bit of an epidemic.
Yeah. The self-
Self-immolation.
Self-immolation. Thank you. Yeah.
Right.
We can kind of ignore a lot of that.
Disney stories always change stuff.
So instead, he's a God, he wants
to be a star and that's exciting.
And then he kind of goes up against maybe
another god that we sort of make up,
like just not be too culturally insensitive
but we just kind of create a bad kind-
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
... whole cloth. You know?
Yeah.
And he's like, "You'll never be a
star." And then Quetzalcoatl has,
I don't know, I was thinking an
Armadillo buddy. I'm not really up
to date on Disney. I don't know how many
of the animal friends there have been.
I don't think we've seen an Armadillo
so I think we can roll with that was
Was the creature in Raya and the Last Dragon
technically an Armadillo? It's kind of a large...
Not quite an armadillo. Don't
worry about it. Don't worry.
Okay. Well, was it voiced by a
slightly out of work 90s comedian?
No.
Because that was a big part of the plan too. If
we can get Andy Dick to come in and voice that.
He's due for a comeback.
It's never going to happen-
He's due for a Disney movie. Yeah.
I think that'd be really fun. So there's hurdles
and there's barriers to his success. But in the
end, Quetzalcoatl gets drunk and hooks up with his
sister, and burns himself to death. That's my...
Great.
My final idea. Okay. And this one's really quick
and I apologize because I've been talking for a
while. But my last idea for a Disney movie, I know
that we've been doing all of these live action
villain origin stories. We did
Maleficent and we did Cruella,
but I feel like we don't have enough of those
for young men who are maybe feeling a little bit
alienated from society and stuff. So I
actually, I do have a vision for this
one and I'm just going to send that to you right
quick. Just let me know what you think of this.
Oh, I like it.
This way we could really tell the origin story
of this character who eventually burned to death.
Good, good. All right, so Nina.
Oh wow. I don't have time to get
into that, into that origin story.
We can skip my whole thing.
No, I love it.
Let's give this one to Nina.
So there's some Disney movies about a young
girl wanting to marry a handsome prince.
Brian, as you mentioned, there are some Disney
stories based on real historical lore. And I
want to combine those two inspired by a recent,
actual musical that I actually do want to see
that is currently playing in both London and soon
to be New York. And I want to bring the story of
Henry VIII and all six of his wives to a Disney
animated film. I think most people are familiar
with Henry VII and the fact that he really... so
a lot of people are like, "He loved killing his
wives." He only killed two of them, and
there were six. So that's only a third.
I learned a rhyme. Do you know the rhyme?
Of course I do. Divorced, beheaded,
died, divorced, beheaded, survived.
Yay.
Yeah. I may have gotten that as a Quizzo
answer multiple times in my life. So I,
I really love the Tudors because they were just
stinky hot messes who slept around and were really
gross. And they were all wildly self-important
and especially Henry... His father at the end
of the War of the Roses just kind of showed up
and was like, "I'll be king," and was pretty
unpopular as a result. And then Henry wasn't
supposed to be king because his older brother,
Arthur was supposed to be king. And then Arthur
died. So all of a sudden Henry was like, "Well,
no one liked my father. My brother died." And he
became king. He first married Catherine of Aragon
and that was a political marriage, but they were
together a long time. He probably did like her.
And then he stopped liking her when she got
old and couldn't have kids anymore because
it was a really fun time to be a woman. So
he started trying to seduce Anne Boleyn,
who would eventually become his second wife, my
favorite. And I'm sure that the commenters will
come from me or they won't because no
one cares about Henry VII's wives but me.
No one watching this cares at all
about Anne Boleyn, Catherine of Aragon,
Anne of Green Gables, any of the wives.
Well, there were two Anne's. You're close.
So yeah. So Anne Boleyn shows up and he's like,
"Oh, be my mistress," and she's like, "No,
I must protect my virtue." Smart move. And he
pursues her for like seven plus years while
he goes through A, the world's longest divorce
and B, starts a new church just so he can get
divorced because Catherine of Aragon refuses
to let him leave. Do you have a question Tom?
Yeah. Do we have a voice cast in mind?
Well, not Jonathan Rhys Meyers.
I've been burned by that before.
Yeah, you don't need that.
I don't know. Maybe we can get like a Paul
Giamatti to put on a British accent and be Henry.
Oh, man.
Paul Giamatti would be fun.
Because the thing is there's no one alive who
can do the full Henry performance because Thomas,
I think you're aware, Henry gets enor- he starts
out as a pretty handsome prince, and then he gets
enormously obese. He has a leg wound that won't
heal from a jousting accident and he just stinks-
Crashes his horse. Yeah.
He's drunk all the time.
So what you're saying is this
is fun for the whole family?
Yeah, and it only gets better. So he marries Anne
Boleyn. Within three months,
he's like, "I hate her too,"
and he kills her and he chops her head off. He
accuses her of all sorts of demented crimes.
Let's rapid fire the other four wives.
Yeah. Jane Seymour was the smartest wife because
she died before she could piss him off, so she was
his favorite. He is buried next to her because
she gave him a son and immediately peaced out.
Smart. Anne of Cleves, the second smartest
because when he decided that she was an
uggo and he didn't like her and tried to get the
marriage annulled, she said, "Okay." And he paid
her handsomely and she ended up outliving him.
Catherine Howard was 15 years old and saddled
with a husband three times her age who smelled
and maybe wasn't exactly virile anymore. So she
cheated on him with one of his courtiers and he
cut her head off too. Catherine Parr almost got
executed because she was reading some books
he didn't like, but luckily he died first.
Was it the toilet guy that she
cheated on him with? Was it the toilet guy?
Well, it might've been the
officer with the bed chamber-
I thought it was his toilet guy.
... or something who took his-
What's a toilet guy, Tom?
Well, he had a servant.
They used to have guys just for toilet.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah. Imagine you're a giant man with
a puss-y, disgusting leg and everything-
I'm imagining it.
... smells like old ham.
Yes, I'm there.
And then you go to the
bathroom. When I say bathroom,
I'm being very generous. It's
a hole in a different room.
Yeah. It's either that or it's a pot
in your room. It's just like hanging out
there, waiting for you to use it. Yeah.
There you go.
It was one of his officers of
the bed chamber. You are correct.
What did the guy do?
You got to bro down.
He-
To his wife?
The toilet guy.
Because-
No. What did the toilet guy do in the toilet?
By the way, his name was
Thomas Culpeper. He has a name.
What did Thomas Culpeper do in-
I prefer toilet-
... with, or around the toilet?
He emptied chamber pots, I believe.
Am I correct? I think he also helped,
I think they were responsible
for helping the king.
Because listen-
It's a lot of fragrance.
Listen, we're talking about Renaissance
medieval, right? One of those periods in England.
Yeah.
We're talking about Disney movies, but somehow...
Well, when you say toilet guy
and especially when it comes
to a Disney movie, let's not forget
Beast's Enchanted Castle, I'm saying-
That's Paul Giamatti.
... he might be a guy into whom
Henry uses the toilet. I don't know.
Oh, you're talking about a
Beauty and the Beast situation?
Yes.
Oh, you mean he's an anthropomorphic
toilets? I can live with that.
That's why I need to know.
What's a toilet guy? Who's the-
Well, and that's what makes it-
... toilet guy?
Can you imagine?
That makes it even better when he has an affair
with the queen. That he's an actual toilet man.
I'm just imagining a Henry VII,
a court where all of the furniture is alive and
sentient and it's all just quiet and they're
all just staring at the ground because of the
things that they've seen. They're all horrified.
And also, if one of them says a word out of turn,
he just throws it right out of the window
and destroys it and murders that too.
Oh, yeah. Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
How do you cut the head off of a teapot? Yeah.
He'll figure it out.
He was a crafty dude. Yeah.
This sounds like a great Disney movie.
Look, I think it would be
just absolutely unhinged.
I am the only person asking for
this, but I'm humbly asking for it.
You are.
Nina-
Tom.
Can you pitch three Disney songs based on
the life, and also who writes... are we doing
like Alan Menken or do we want to do like a
later days Disney thing where we bring in?
No, I totally want Alan Menken. Thank you for
bringing his name into it. I love him. Maybe
I want Stephen Sondheim to consult because maybe
we need that edge and all those dissonant notes.
But we're not doing Sting or-
Yeah.
... Phil Collins or anything.
I think Anne of Cleves would be like, "I'm not
that ugly," but written mostly by Stephen
Sondheim. "I'm not that ugly. I promise."
That's really pretty. I can already hear it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Catherine Parr, "Thank God"-
Cleves me alone.
"Thank God he died," wife number six.
Great.
Yeah. And Anne Boleyn, "It's not my fault
I couldn't have a son, you weirdo." Yeah.
That's really nice. Those are great.
Thank you. Anyway.
Good job.
Those are my songs. That's my pitch. I expect
a call from someone with the
last name Disney within the hour.
Can I loop back briefly to Tom's and to say that-
Oh, I thought you were going
to say toilet guy. But yeah.
Well, we can talk more about toilet
guy. I was just going to say, after
Her-Two-Les, it's Hercu-Three's.
Oh, there's the next one.
Goodnight. Bye. Thanks for watching.
Please hit like and subscribe so
you don't miss a single video.